Now that we've gone over the Brush Setup properties, let's get hands on and talk about
layout and storyboarding inside of Unreal Engine.
So let's open our editor and then inside our editor, I want to create a new folder.
It's up to you how you organize these folders.
The folder name isn't necessarily relevant here.
I've just called it EPOS.
I'm going to right click in some empty space.
I'm going to go to Animation and Level Sequence.
These are the steps that we spoke about at the start of the course here.
I'm just going to call it SEQ for Sequencer, underscore master, underscore 01, something
like this.
Again, the naming convention doesn't really matter for this purpose, but I'm just going
to create a new level sequence and then I will open that up.
I will also go to the drop down at the top and I will click Start Storyboarding.
So we'll click this.
And this is our properties that we spoke about before.
So you can name it My Storyboard 01.
You can call it the name of whatever project you're currently working on.
You can set a desired path.
If you want, I'm going to select the EPOS path.
But again, wherever you would like to put these files, studio name, you've got
board naming conventions.
Feel free to go into any of these properties as we spoke about earlier in the course
and edit those to whatever you would desire.
I'm just going to go ahead and click Create Storyboard for now though.
So we've got our storyboard.
We've got our boards here.
We can start thinking about adding a new shot.
So let's go ahead and click New Shot on the plus shot.
And we've got our shots here.
So we've still got our scene.
We've got our sequence, the layout, but we've not got any cameras.
The first thing we want to do is to go ahead and add a camera.
So we can do that by clicking this button here, Create New Camera.
And you can name your camera, whatever name and conventions you like to use.
You can change the film back settings.
You can give the plane a name.
Again, I won't worry too much about naming conventions for this quick demonstration.
But of course, when you're working on a larger project, you'll want to set up
naming conventions in advance.
I'm going to go ahead and create a new camera and its plane here.
And you can see that we're piloting the camera.
And we can see the camera here.
I'll just zoom in on this storyboard sequence by holding down Control
and mouse wheeling over there.
I can also hold Shift and mouse wheel backwards and forwards.
That helps navigate the space.
But essentially, this is our this is our shot here.
And now we want to start thinking about how to draw using this plugin.
To do that, we go to the top left here on Select Mode.
And you'll see that we have this now shift to Iliad as an option.
So we can select here.
By default, this is the window that opens.
You want to give yourself a bit of real estate.
On in your editor, because we want a few different options open here.
So by default, we've got top bar that we want to click open.
And that will give us access to a few useful properties here.
We've got the brush selector that we want to add.
And I just I normally pin these down here.
This is the way I learned how to use the program.
And then also the layers tool, which I generally stack below the top bar
on the brush selector.
You want the layers to be in its own panel really,
because you want the ability to quickly switch between layers.
And then also tools is a useful window to have open.
Maybe just pin that on the right hand side for your fill tool
and to undo any other elements that you want to undo.
So these are generally the windows that you may use most often.
Again, figuring out the real estate.
And maybe if you have a second monitor, you can create a better layout.
But overall, this is these are the tools that you want open to start creating.
And then when we have our plane, we can actually just start
the drawing process from whichever frame we want to look at.
So again, if we drew a little stick figure, I don't have a tablet plugged in.
So mind my mouse skills here.
You can see that I've drawn a little figure here.
And if we want to then add a new shot here, you can click the drawing.
And so I just click the drawing here.
And maybe you've got someone over here.
Maybe that's the same person we want to show movement like
like the ball over the net or something like this.
And what's interesting is then you can see the frames switching.
And what's a really useful feature as well, if you click this little light bulb icon,
you can actually see the previous drawing you want.
So if you want to.
Kind of toggle between a few frames and know where the previous frame was,
you can use that light bulb mode there.
So of course, you can get into way more detail.
There's a lot of different options to jump into
diving to all these different properties.
And also if you are painting, you can show the background.
If you're in a quite a busy scene, this scene is quite straightforward.
But if you've got a busy scene and you want to alpha out more of the scene
and you want to block it out so you can really just focus on your drawings,
you can go ahead and do that.
You can drop the alpha back down to see more of the screen.
And of course, you can change the grid as well, either the grid type.
If this blue grid isn't what you want, you can change it into the third grid.
You can even change the grid color.
But there's so many properties in this plugin.
You can really go to town on creating various shots, as we spoke about earlier
in the tutorial, but they're the quick settings to get up and running
with drawing directly into your storyboard.
And so hopefully that added some clarity on a bit of a hands-on demonstration
of how to use this plugin and now we'll move on to the next section.